So today I want to say just a little bit
more about revenue equivalents or the
revenue formula that we wrote down and I
think this will be useful
for the problem set and the quiz on
Friday. And then I'm going to talk about
an application of auctions to display
advertising auctions, like the kinds of
auctions, the keyword auctions that
Google does
commonly today.
Just a reminder of this revenue formula
that we computed. We were looking at a
single item auction and we had this
formula, maybe I'll write it down here
where we said TI hat of VI
which was the equilibrium expected
payment by a bidder with valuation VI
was equal to
this.
So we said the expected payment of a
bidder with valuation VI in this
equilibrium
is equal to the expected payment of
bidder I when she has the lowest
possible valuation plus this integral of
maybe this kind of mysterious term of X
times the derivative of this function Q
hat where remember this is the
derivative
of the allocation probability.
So I just want to highlight a few
assumptions that were required to get
this result and the problem set is going
to explore some ways this assumption
this result can break. Yes? Is there a
reason why the lower bound of the
integral Ah, yes, that should be V lower
bar, sorry.
Yeah, thanks.
So a few assumptions we made. One was
the assumption of independent
private values.
Independence says statistical
independence. It says one bidder's
valuation is statistically independent
of another bidder's valuation.
Private values, private is kind of a
confusing term. I think maybe known
values
is maybe a more descriptive term. It
means that each bidder knows exactly how
much they value the good. Information
that another bidder has is not relevant
to my valuation of the item. And I still
think that's a bit abstract, so I'm
going to go over an example where this
fails in a second and I think that
should clarify the role of this
assumption.
The other assumption we made
notice we took an integral here over
some range of values. So another
important assumption is that the values
maybe I'll say live in an interval.
So if instead a player's valuation could
only be say $1 or $2, it's not an
interval, it's just two points, then we
wouldn't be able to take an integral
between one and $2 and this formula
would no longer hold. And the problem
set will show you an example of this.
One other maybe more technical
assumption you might notice is that
well, for this to make sense, this
function Q hat has to be well-behaved.
We have to be able to take the
derivative of Q hat.
That's a more technical thing, so I'll
just say technical
QI hat is differentiable.
I call this technical because it turns
out if you use a more involved proof,
you can get a substantially similar
result without this assumption. So
that's not something we're going to
cover in the course, but I'll just
highlight that uh
our proof used differentiability of Q
hat, but that's not really necessary for
the result.
But these assumptions really are
substantive and important for this
revenue formula.
Okay. So to understand what private
values mean,
let's look at a
classic example without private values,
which is called a wallet auction.
You know, I don't think anyone actually
does auctions like this, but it's a good
illustration. So I think there's a few
stories for this. The basic story is
that I guess this happened like at a
bar. You have two people at a bar, they
each get out their wallet and they put
their wallet in a bowl, say or or in a
pile
on the table. So you have
player one's wallet and player two's
wallet.
And then
the players bid for the union of the two
wallets.
So we have both their wallets together
in a bowl.
We're now each going to submit a bid.
Whoever bids more gets the bowl, but has
to pay that amount.
Um
Now, what's special about this auction?
I mean the story maybe is is kind of
far-fetched, but the important thing is
I know as player one what's in my wallet
but I don't know what's in the other
player's wallet.
The other player knows what's in their
wallet, but they don't know what's in my
wallet, right? So maybe we'll call the
amount in my wallet theta one and the
amount in the other person's wallet
theta two.
And just to make it simple, let's say
theta one and theta two
just to clarify exactly which assumption
we're relaxing, let's say theta one and
theta two are
independent and uniform.
Independent
and uniform over zero one. You know,
that's just a normalization. One could
be, you know, one billion or something.
Um
Okay, but the key point is that bidder
one
knows theta one
but not theta two.
Because they don't know what's in the
other person's wallet. So if I'm bidder
one, I say I know my wallet say has .3
but all for all I know the other
person's wallet is uniformly distributed
between zero and one. That's all I know
because I can't see what's in their
wallet. And symmetrically bidder two
knows
theta two
but not theta one.
Now, why is this not a setting of
private values? Well, I do know
something.
I know theta one, I know what's in my
wallet, but I don't know the joint value
of our two wallets.
And more specifically, something the
other player knows is relevant for my
valuation of the bowl, of the of the
item. So what makes it not private
values, so maybe I'll say here it's a
failure of private values.
Why? Because my willingness to pay, my
valuation depends on information that
another player has. Or maybe more
precisely
another player and other players
information
influences or affects my valuation for
the item. Where here the item is the
combination of the two wallets.
Maybe I'll say my willingness to pay.
If the other player's wallet contains a
dollar, which only the other player
knows, I'd be willing to pay more for
this bowl that contains both of our
wallets.
Now you might say, well, okay, I don't
know exactly what's in the other wallet,
but I can compute expectations. So kind
of the naive approach might be well,
let's try to treat this like a normal
private values auction. So here I'll
write naive approach to say this is
going to be wrong, but let's let's see
what happens.
Under the naive approach, if I'm player
one
what would I say is my
willingness to pay for the
the bowl. If someone if I just, you
know, looked at it, I know theta one,
what's like a reasonable way to say what
is my willingness to pay? What is my
expected value from
the union of the two wallets or the sum
of the two wallets?
Yeah?
Since the other player's value is
uniformly distributed between zero and
one, the expected value of the other
person's value is .5. So the naive
approach would be to add .5 to player
one's value.
Exactly right. So we might say, okay,
this is just a normal auction where
player one's value is theta one plus .5
or plus a half.
And player two's value
is theta two plus a half.
So we might say, look, we have some item
and I have some private information. I
know my theta one, I use that to compute
my valuation and let's just go ahead
like this. And what I want to show is
that this auction is going to behave
very differently
from a private values auction where this
is my value and this is the other
player's value.
So to see this, let's look at I'm not
going to so fully solving this auction
is quite involved and
I'll leave that to the notes and we
won't really cover that in this course.
We will cover it in 1416 in the spring
if you're interested in that, but
let's just imagine we did a second price
auction.
And let's imagine that we looked for an
equilibrium
where
each player bids truthfully. Okay? So
let's look at a strategy profile
where player one bids
I'll say B1 of theta one
equals theta one plus a half
and B2 of theta two
equals theta two plus a
Now
if this were a private values auction
then this strategy profile would be an
equilibrium. Right? We already argued
that in a classical private values
single item auction, it was an
equilibrium for each player to bid
truthfully, to bid their valuation for
the item.
And in fact, we argued more, we said
however the other player bids, it's
optimal for me to bid my valuation in a
second price auction.
So let's kind of see what goes wrong
in this case.
So
let's suppose that
to make things simple, let's say theta
one is 0.4
and theta two equals 0.3.
So, if that happens, then player one
is supposed to bid 0.9.
And player two is supposed to bid 0.8,
right? 0.5 + 0.3.
So, this would be player two's bid.
And this would be player one's bid.
Now, how would our reasoning for
why bidding B1 is
optimal go? Well, if this were private
values, we would say, "Okay,
I'm bidder one.
My valuation is 0.9.
If I bid truthfully, what happens? Well,
I get the item and I pay 0.8.
And 0.8 is less than 0.9.
So, I'm doing well.
And if I deviated, well, if I deviate to
bid any amount more than 0.8, it's not
going to make a difference. I'm still
going to win.
And I'm still going to pay 0.8. And if I
deviate to any amount less than 0.8,
well, I'm going to lose and I'm going to
get a payoff of zero. So, the naive
argument might be
"Well, I'm bidding optimally. Why?
Because 0.1
is greater than zero."
And maybe I should explain where this
comes from, 0.9 - 0.8.
So, it looks like I'm doing well. I get
a payoff of 0.1.
I could do no better than 0.1. I'm
bidding optimally. That would be the
private values intuition.
What's wrong with this?
So, everything I said was was wrong.
Yeah. Your actual value is negative 0.1
cuz the value is 0.7 and you're bidding
0.8.
You're paying 0.8.
Exactly right. And this is getting at
the key point that it's not it's not
really the case that my value is known
to be 0.9. That was just my expected
value without getting any additional
information about the other player. The
problem is if the other player bids 0.8
and the reason they bid 0.8 is that
their value of their wallet is 0.3, that
changes the amount that I value the
wallet.
I no longer value it at 0.9. What do I
value it at? Well, the true value of the
wallet to me is the sum of theta one
plus theta two,
which in this case is going to be
0.7.
So, if I bid truthfully here,
I'm going to pay 0.8 for something
that's only worth 0.7 to me.
What changed? And why is it different
from the classical auction? It's that
well, this 0.9 wasn't my true valuation
of the item. It was my belief or my
expected uh value of the item.
And unfortunately, my assessment of the
value of the item is influenced by the
other player's private information. So,
the issue is when I won, I'm winning
precisely because the other player's
wallet doesn't have much money in it.
And this phenomenon, which I mean, this
is a very simple example. Uh maybe you
think, "Oh, this doesn't have relevance
to the real world." But this is actually
uh
a really serious problem when in a lot
of real auctions and it's something
called the winner's curse.
So, it sounds good for player one here.
Player one won the auction. The problem
is we have to think, "Why did player one
win?"
Well, when will player one win this
auction?
The uh yeah, go ahead.
No, when their wallet has more money
Yeah, they'll win the auction when the
other person bids a lower amount, which
is precisely when the other person's
valuation is low.
And the other person's wallet doesn't
have very much. So, the winner's curse
is that you tend to win
when the item is less valuable.
And if you don't take this into account,
people will tend to overbid and the
person who wins the auction will tend to
come away a loser because they'll
overpay for an item that's not worth
very much. Now, just a few examples
where this has happened in practice.
And you know, firms in the '70s and '80s
lost tons of money uh making mistakes
like this. One example would be
oil drilling.
And someone
maybe walk me through how oil drilling
has anything to do with uh this wallet
auction and why firms might uh
be subject to the winner's curse. So,
here we're drilling for oil
and we're bidding for attractive land.
Uh so, oil drilling
and let's say an auction
for land. So, it's
for land rights, I'll say.
So, there's some big plot of land, say
in Alaska in the Arctic.
We are bidding for the right to drill
for oil in that land and we're different
oil firms. Yeah.
Maybe you like a lot of firms ended up
paying more than the oil they would
actually get
So, that's exactly what happened and and
why why did that happen?
Um
I guess
others put more than they got caught up
in the auction just trying to make most
of the person who's selling and ended up
Right. So, I think we're along the right
track. Any other thoughts about maybe a
little more specificity? Uh yeah, in
blue. Yeah.
The person who's going to win is going
to be the one who thinks there's the
most oil there and
assuming there's a range that's uh
people's beliefs and it falls somewhere
in the middle, they're going to have
overvalued it. Exactly. So, the crucial
thing here is what are we doing when
we're a firm bidding on this? We're
going to make a noisy estimate of the
amount of oil in the land. So, the issue
here is
noisy or imprecise estimates.
SO, I'M GOING TO DO A LITTLE TESTING,
RIGHT? I'm going to try to guess
or estimate how much oil is in this this
land.
Every other firm is going to do the same
thing.
If I win, what does that mean about my
estimate relative to everyone else's?
Means my estimate was higher than
everyone else's.
And if my estimate was higher than
everyone else's, it probably means my
estimate was just was an overestimate of
the true value of the of the land and
I'm going to end up paying too much. Um
another example where this happens is uh
auctions for
say government
procurement.
So, this is kind of the analog of this.
What what happens there? The government
says, "We want to build a subway."
And now the firms are going to bid on
the amount that they need to get paid to
build the subway. So, I might say, "I'll
build it for 100 million." Someone else
says, "I'll build it for 110 million."
Someone else says, "I'll build it for 90
million." And the government chooses the
lowest bidder. So, these you always have
to be careful here. So, the winner
is the lowest bidder.
Because the government wants it built as
cheaply as possible, right? Now, I think
something else that can be a similar
winner's curse here. What's the what's
the story in a government procurement
auction?
Say we're building a subway in New York.
Yeah.
To build the subway, there's unknown
kind of costs that are not fully
certain. And so again, you're making a
noisy estimate of exactly how much it's
going to cost to make the subway. And
then whoever wins is going to be whoever
had the lowest estimate of cost, which
is probably wrong. [snorts] Exactly
right. So, it's exactly parallel to
this, right? We're making noisy
estimates. Here, we're estimating the
value of something. If I win, I probably
overestimated the value.
Here, we're estimating the cost of doing
something. If I won, I probably
underestimated the cost. So, I thought
it would only cost me 100 million. Then
I uh I build it and uh it ends up
costing a lot more. So, it's the same
basic idea that we have imprecise
estimates that are all correlated.
There's actually a really nice story.
So, Paul Milgrom, who did some famous
work on this and ultimately won the
Nobel Prize, said his dad was a painter
and and would always complain to him
that when he would bid on painting
contracts, he'd always find that when he
won, it cost more to paint the house
than he expected. It was always a bit of
a harder job than he thought. And Paul
Milgrom said, "Oh, one day I wanted to
tell him, you know,
the answer." It turned out his father
died before he could tell him. So, it's
it's a sad story, but um
I think it's sort of a nice illustration
of of this phenomenon.
Uh okay. Any questions on that? And then
we'll move to another application.
Okay. So, now
let's
uh
move to big application of auctions,
which is going to be advertising
auctions.
And by advertising, what I really mean
is
or keyword search auctions.
And you know, you probably see this all
the time.
If you Google something, you know, you
get the organic results. So, let's just
see what it looks like on a page. If I
go to Google,
well, I'm going to get some organic
search results.
What do I mean by organic? Organic just
means Google's algorithm is saying these
are the websites that are most relevant
for what I typed in.
But then you're also going to have
sponsored results, right? You might have
something here.
Say I'll say S for sponsored one. Maybe
something here, S2. Maybe you'll have a
few over here.
S3, S4.
And
these slots, if you look, they'll be
kind of relevant to what you searched.
Um
and you may not even notice. I think you
probably know, but a lot of people just
think of all the results are the same
and they don't quite recognize uh
what's sponsored and what's not. What
does it mean if it's sponsored? Do
people know what what's going on there?
What's the difference in organic and
sponsored?
Uh
yeah.
I don't know exactly what
They paid to have it there. So, if you
notice, if you let's say you
Google Uber
just as one example.
Uh what might you see in the first slot
if you if you Google Uber?
Yeah.
You often see Lyft, right? Um and what's
happening
is Uber will probably show up as the
first organic result,
but the first sponsored result might
actually be Lyft.
Because Lyft recognizes that someone
who's searching for Uber is looking to
rideshare and maybe Lyft can kind of
undermine can undermine them and get
them to buy that. Now Uber might
actually buy a slot here as well to try
to do that and now we might see so Uber
might actually appear both in the
organic results and in the sponsored
results and there's a lot of strategy
that goes on
into this.
And this is actually how Google makes a
lot of their money, right? That by
having the best search engine they have
a lot of people searching and firms are
willing to pay a lot for these slots.
Now a big insight a big kind of
advantage for Google was the fact that
these slots are responsive to the
keyword. So I'll say the sponsored slots
depend
on the keyword. The keyword meaning what
you what you Googled.
Before this Google would just do banner
advertisements where they would just
have something on the screen that was
shown to everyone. But that's not very
valuable because I might be showing an
ad to someone who doesn't really care
about it. So by
these sponsored searches allow Google to
hyper target their ads and therefore
generate a lot more revenue from their
ads.
Now how does Google decide who gets to
be in this slot, who gets to be in this
slot, who gets to be in this slot? They
run an auction among the advertisers and
this is actually you know maybe in in
numerical terms the the most important
auctions we see in the world billions
hundreds of billions are raised every
year doing this and today we're going to
analyze a very simple model of this kind
of sponsored search auction.
So just to be clear here the entire
auction is designed for a particular
keyword. If people Google Lyft then
there's going to be an auction for
showing slots to someone who Googled
Lyft. If someone Googled Uber there
would be a different thing if they
Googled Googled a hotel there would be
something else. So everything we're
going to be talking about is for a fixed
keyword.
Now why can't we just off the shelf
apply what we've done so far? The
challenge is this is not a single
item auction.
We have many items. We have the first
slot, we have the second slot, we have
the third slot. And the other thing is
these items are not the same. So it's
not a single item auction. We have
multiple
heterogeneous items.
Or maybe I'll say differentiated items.
Getting shown first is a lot better than
being shown second which is better than
being shown third. So how do we model
this? Well we're going to write down
pretty simple model and here's our
general model.
We're going to say that if your ad shows
up in the first slot it's more likely to
be clicked. Right? So in our general
model we have n bidders.
I'll call them
i equals one to m n sorry.
And then we're going to have m
advertising slots. So in my example up
here we had four in general we'll have m
advertising slots.
We'll call these j equals one to m.
And what distinguishes these slots is
what we'll call the click-through rate.
So
I'll say
the click
through rate
sometimes called CTR
are alpha one
alpha two
alpha m. So what does this mean?
Alpha one is the click-through rate of
the first position.
If someone shows their ad in the first
position this is the probability that
it's going to get clicked.
If someone shows their ad in the second
position then the probability that it
gets clicked is alpha two all the way
down to alpha m if it's shown in the mth
position. Now there's a big simplifying
assumption here that the probability
that it's clicked doesn't depend on
which ad is shown there, right? If I
showed a really bad ad for a really
undesirable product even if it's first
probably no one's going to click on it.
But
if we're looking at products that are
pretty similar like Uber and Lyft maybe
this is a a reasonable assumption.
We're next going to assume that each of
the bidders we have to specify well what
do the bidders know? Well we're going to
assume the bidders have valuations per
click. So the bidders
so let's say bidder i
has valuation
vi per click.
The idea would be if someone clicks on
my ad well maybe they'll buy it maybe
they won't but the expected value to me
of someone clicking on my ad is vi.
Another simplifying assumption here is
that we're saying
if someone clicks on it when it's in the
first position versus someone clicks on
it when it's in the second position
that's equally valuable to me. That may
not be a good assumption maybe if
someone clicks on it even when it's in a
bad position maybe it's more valuable
because those people really like it but
we're not going to
focus on on that. We're going to keep it
simple.
Okay.
So now I'm Google
I have these m slots. I have these i
bidders. I'm going to ask them to submit
bids and I need to choose then choose so
what do I need to choose? Let's go back
over here.
So Google has
maybe I'll call this auction design
choices.
So one first choice is well I'm going to
ask people to pay me but am I going to
ask them to pay me every time someone
clicks on the ad or am I going to ask
them to pay me just every time the ad is
shown? And these are two common models
for these auctions. One is called pay
per click
and one is called pay per impression.
An impression means the ad is shown to
someone but not necessarily clicked on
may or may not be clicked on.
In in our model this actually won't make
a difference because we're assuming that
the click-through rates are perfectly
known.
In a more realistic model people might
be uncertain about these click-through
rates and then it does make a big
difference whether it's pay per click or
pay per impression. I might want pay per
click if I'm really uncertain about how
popular my ad is because then if my ad
turns out to be a failure and no one
clicks on it well then I don't at least
at least I don't have to pay very much.
Whereas if it's paid for impression well
then I'm on the hook to keep showing my
ad no one's clicking on it and I'm still
paying for it. So you can see why it's
it's pretty common to use pay per click.
You can think of this as kind of
insuring advertisers against having a
really bad ad that no one wants to click
on. But in this model that won't make a
difference. Yes Amy. But then doesn't
Google lose out on pay per click if all
the ads are pretty unpopular?
Yeah I mean I guess
the firms would still have an incentive
to
uh
have good ads. Yeah I mean I guess you
might worry a little bit maybe about
moral hazard. I mean
the
the pay per click
if the payment for click was too high
then maybe firms wouldn't have an
incentive to improve their ads.
I guess there is a bit of an incentive
trade-off there but I think the firms
still have a pretty you know Google can
still tell the firms no one's clicking
on your ad.
And the firms still want their ads to be
clicked on. But I agree their incentives
may not be quite as strong in that case.
Yeah.
So there's sort of a trade-off there
between
maybe insurance and incentives but
yeah.
And over time I think the firms learn a
lot about
about how often the likelihood of their
ad being clicked on.
So today we're going to use pay per
click. Again in our model it won't
matter but this will just simplify
things, right? So what is what does the
auctioneer say? Well the auction's going
to collect the bids and the bids are
going to be payments per click. So my
bid is going to say think of it roughly
as how much am I willing to pay each
time my ad is clicked on. So we're going
to collect these bids
b1
through bn.
And then what do we need to decide? Well
we need to have an allocation. So we
have
slot one slot two up to slot m. For each
slot we have to say
who gets it.
So which ad is shown in this slot?
And then the payment per click.
So this is you know formally what we're
choosing. We're choosing a function that
says if these are the the n bids that
the advertisers submit
who are we going to put in the first
slot and how much are we going to ask
them to pay per click?
Who are we going to put in the second
slot and how much are we going to ask
them to pay per click? All the way down
to the mth slot. So that's the the
choice we have to make.
And of course the design of the auction
that we use is going to affect the
bidding behavior of the advertisers,
right? We could use this there's various
auction formats. So
today the first auction format we're
going to look at is what's called a GSP
or generalized second price auction.
And I think we can kind of maybe guess
how this works. You know how a second
price auction works. Why do we call it
generalized? Well a classic second price
auction applies when there's a single
item that we're auctioning off. Here we
have multiple items so we have to
generalize it.
And I think this is kind of the most
intuitive generalization. Any ideas
about if you had to think how it let's
say you're working at Google someone
said let's generalize a second price
auction what might you do here?
Well let's first think about the
allocation. I think that's pretty easy.
Who do you think you're going to show in
the first slot? Who's that?
The highest bidder. The highest bidder,
right? So, it's sort of the allocation
rule kind of makes sense. We'll show the
highest bidder here, the second highest
bidder here, all the way down to the mth
highest bidder here, right? So,
in general, maybe I'll
put it here. We're in slot k, so slot k
is going to go to the kth highest
bidder.
I'm good then.
But now, maybe the harder thing is
what's the payment per click? What's a
reasonable amount to charge the kth
highest bidder
per click? Any? The k plus k plus first.
Right. That's a pretty natural way of
doing it, right? We say, "Okay, you're
the kth highest bidder, so you get the
kth slot, but we're not going to charge
you your bid, we're going to charge you
the next highest bid, right?" Um in a
second price auction, you can think of
the second price as the second as the
next highest bid after the winner, and
here we're charging the next highest bid
after the person who wins the kth slot.
So, the payment, maybe I'll call it pk,
uh
is equal to
k plus first.
highest bid.
Okay, this seems pretty intuitive, and
let's let's try to get a feel for how
this works
uh in an example.
What would happen like in in the end
like the last person?
Uh good point. So,
there's a question of, you know, what's
the relationship between m and n?
Um
usually the last person uh would pay, so
if uh the last, you know, m may be
smaller than n, but if m is equal to n,
the next highest bid we would usually
call zero. So, we can imagine we have
the n bids, and then imagine the n plus
first bid is just zero.
So, the first one wouldn't pay They
wouldn't pay anything. Now, in reality,
m is probably much smaller than n,
right? So, if m is smaller than n, then
the mth highest bidder is going to pay
the m plus first highest bid, and then m
plus two, m plus three, m plus four,
they don't get anything at all. So, what
you're describing can only happen if
there's more bidders than ad slots. And
that kind of makes sense, right? If
there's Sorry, if there's more ad slots
than bidders. If there's as many or more
ad slots than bidders, then
you know, we we can't really charge much
because, you know, we can just give them
away, right? Okay.
But good question.
This is
Okay, so let's go through
a simple example to make sure
you understand. So, let's do a example
with
m equals
maybe two
and n equals three. So, we have three
bidders and two ad slots, and let's say
the ad slots we have ad slot one,
which has click-through rate alpha one,
and we have ad slot two, which has
click-through rate alpha two.
And we're always assuming that alpha
that they're in descending order, so
alpha one is strictly greater than alpha
two.
And let's say the bidders submit these
bids that maybe b1 is
uh $7,
b2 is $8, and bid three is $5, okay?
So now, what's going to happen in this
auction?
Well, the first slot is going to go to
the bidder who bids the most. In this
case, that's bidder two.
So, bidder two's ad is going to be
they're going to show bidder two's ad.
And in the second slot, they're going to
show the second highest bidder, which in
this case is bidder one. So, they're
going to show bidder one's ad.
And what is the payment per click going
to be?
So, maybe I'll call this p1 and p2. So,
p I'll try to use superscripts for
positions and subscripts for bidders,
right? So, p1 is not necessarily bidder
one, it's the payment made per click for
the first ad slot.
So, in this case, the highest bidder bid
eight, the second highest bid was seven,
so p1 is going to be
seven. So, bidder two is going to pay
have to pay $7 per click.
And now, if we go to two, well, the the
second highest bidder is going to pay
the third highest bid, which in this
case is five, so p2 is going to be five.
Okay, [snorts] this all
sounds good.
But now, we might ask, well,
is it optimal to bid truthfully?
We know in a standard second price
auction it is, you you should bid
truthfully, but now things are a little
more complicated.
So, let's take the perspective of bidder
two.
Well, what is their expected profit
going to be
from bidding truthfully? That is,
bidding eight in this auction.
So, let's assume, I guess I haven't been
clear, let's assume that v2 equals
eight. So, let's
suppose the true value is eight and they
bid eight, what is their uh
what are they going to get
in expectation?
Well, let's go through it. The
probability they're being shown in slot
one,
the probability their ad gets clicked is
alpha one,
and each time it's clicked, their
valuation per click is eight,
but they end up having to pay seven.
So, we get alpha one times eight minus
seven,
which is just alpha one, right?
But let's suppose that instead
they
bid a bit less.
And let's suppose that instead of
bidding eight, they bid six.
So,
so this is a bid of eight,
but let's suppose instead they bid six.
>> [snorts]
>> Well, now what's going to happen?
Now, what's their expected payment?
Well, if they bid six, where is their ad
going to be shown?
Yeah.
It'll be the second slot, right? If they
bid six, bidder one is going to get the
first slot, bidder two is now going to
get the second slot, so they're going to
get alpha two.
Their value is still eight, but now
how much do they pay?
Yeah.
They're going to pay five, right?
Because now um
they're getting the second slot, they're
going to pay the third highest bid, the
highest bid is seven, the second highest
bid is six, the third highest bid is
five, right?
So, we get three alpha two.
Well, what's better?
Well, it's going to depend on the
relative values of alpha one and alpha
two.
And in particular,
if alpha two is pretty close to alpha
one, they're going to be much better off
shading their bid.
So, this is going to be preferred
if alpha two is close to alpha one,
right? It's smaller than alpha one, but
if it's close.
And here we see a fundamental difference
between a standard second price auction
and the generalized second price
auction.
In the standard second price auction,
you want to bid truthfully because if
you don't get the item, you don't get
anything.
But in a multi-item auction, now it's
less clear. If you shade your bid,
instead of getting nothing, you get the
next slot. And if the next slot is
almost as good as the first slot, you
might as well shade your bid. You might
as well reduce your bid. So, we now have
a much stronger temptation to reduce
your bid when the penalty for losing is
lower. Instead of getting nothing, I
just go one slot down. And in
particular, when these slots are very
close, going one slot down is not very
costly.
So now, we need to ask, well, we could
use this bidding bidding format, but
then bidders have to, you know, spend a
lot of money trying to figure out how
much other people are going to bid, and
their bids going to depend on other
people's bids, and it's going to be
complicated. So, maybe we want an
auction where it's optimal for people to
just bid truthfully. So, we want a
different generalization of the second
price auction than what's called a
generalized second price auction. Yes.
Does this generalized bidder decrease
revenue for the auctioneer because
everyone's going to shade?
Uh
that's kind of uh
it's a sort of question. So,
uh
there is an equilibrium of this auction
that will give
I guess we have to say, what is the
comparison with? Um
the auction format that we're going to
describe next, the VCG auction, there
will be an equilibrium of this auction
that will give the same revenue in this,
but that's in this very stylized example
where there's no uncertainty. Um if you
added some more realistic features, then
you have to be a little more careful,
and it's it's actually not so clear.
Yeah. So, so the auctioneer doesn't have
a preference between
like the style of the second price
auction? So, I I think the question is
some of the theorems say it doesn't
matter, but those theorems make some
very strong assumptions that people bid
exactly according to the equilibrium,
and we know in practice that that
doesn't really happen. So, in fact, one
concern there was, going back
historically, is people using a
basically a first price a version of a
first price auction of this, and there
was a suggestion that people should that
we should move to um
to a second price uh auction. But the
concern was, well, if we jump right away
to a second price auction, and firms
don't adjust their bidding behavior, now
we're going to lose a lot of money. So
the second price auction should give you
as much revenue if we played the new
equilibrium where people bid much
differently. But if firms don't know
that and they don't react quickly
enough, then there's really a strong
disincentive to move to a second price
auction. I think that's one issue that
went on. So I there's kind of a gap
between the theory and the and the
applications here. Um
I guess I should say the real I guess
the
maybe the
the fundamental issue that motivated a
lot of this auction work was that firms
are able to modify their bids quickly in
real time. So the firm submits some
bids, their ads shown, and then they can
change their bids over time. And what
was happening is firms were constantly
changing their bids and there were these
bids were going in cycles. So we're
modeling this as kind of a one-off
interaction.
If we use
the auction format we're going to
describe, I think that's a good model,
but if if people really care about how
other people bid, then it can make
things a lot more complicated when
people can change their bids over time.
Good question.
Okay, so let's think about uh how else
we can generalize the second price
auction. And I think the key is to think
about the second price auction a bit
differently.
So I think the most obvious way to
generalize the second price auction is
to say, "Well, what is the second price
auction? You pay the second highest bid,
so let's generalize it you pay the next
highest bid." But let's think about it
what's really going on in the second
price auction a bit differently.
Another way of thinking about a second
price auction
is that each bidder is asked to pay
their externality.
Let's understand what we mean by this.
So let's say the valuations are ordered.
It's like V2
to VN.
And
let's say I'm this guy
and I win, okay?
So I'm the highest bidder. Let's suppose
everyone's bidding truthfully, I guess,
to make this argument. I win, I get my
valuation of V1, and these guys all
lose, right?
Now
what if I weren't here
and we just wanted to allocate the good
in a way that was efficient for everyone
else? What would we do if if if bidder
one were not here?
Who would we allocate it to?
Bidder two. And what would they get?
Their valuation would be V2.
Right? So we can say
if bidder one
were gone
then
the total value of that all the other
bidders would get would be V2. Bidder
one were gone, the item
would go to bidder two.
And the value
would be V2.
So we can think of it as, "Well,
the total value that everyone other than
bidder one gets is zero when bidder one
is here
and would have been two if bidder one
were not present."
So the externality that bidder one's
presence or bidder one's bid imposes on
everyone else is exactly V2. Because
they take the item away from everyone
else, and the most efficient allocation
of it everyone else would have been to
bidder V2.
So this is the aspect of the second
price auction that we're next going to
try to generalize. We're going to try to
charge people the externality that their
presence imposed on everyone else.
In this case that externality happens to
be the second highest valuation, the
second highest bid, but in general it's
not necessarily. And that's what we'll
see with the
with the next auction format.
So
let's look at this.
So let's say that we bid
uh
B1
B2
B3
and let's suppose that these are ordered
like this.
And we have these slots 1 2 3.
Now if I'm the highest bidder then I get
slot one.
The second highest bidder gets slot two,
and the third highest bidder gets slot
three.
So here I'm just assuming bidder one's
the highest, bidder two's the second
highest, and bidder three is is next.
Well, what would happen if
bidder one
were not present?
If bidder one weren't here, or in other
words, if bidder one just bid zero and
didn't win anything
what would happen to bidder two? Which
slot would they get?
They'd move up to the first slot, right?
So they'd go up here.
And bidder three similarly would move up
to the second slot.
So
let's now compute
bidder one's the highest bidder's
externality.
Well, bidder two
the externality is that they're pushed
down from alpha one to alpha two at the
as their click-through rate.
So we have
B2.
So what happens?
Bidder two
gets alpha two instead of alpha one as
their click-through rate.
And their value per click uh
let's treat it as their bid B2.
This is the externality imposed on
bidder two.
And this is the externality imposed on
bidder three. Notice here we have to be
a little careful to directly compute the
externality
we'd have to know how much other people
actually value the item. So when we
compute the externality, we compute it
as if people are bidding truthfully. So
I don't actually know how much bidder
two values the slot, but we're going to
compute the externality as if they were
bidding truthfully. So if bidder two
were bidding truthfully, then the amount
they value the slot per click is exactly
B2. And their loss is the difference in
click-through rate times their valuation
per click. And similarly B3, their loss
is the difference in click-through rate
times their valuation here.
So
in general we want to the idea or the
goal
to charge each bidder
their externality.
So let's now motivated by this simple
example, let's see if we can give a
general formula for this auction format.
And this is called
a VCG auction, and this is named after
three people
Vickrey
won the Nobel Prize for this, Clark
and Groves.
>> [clears throat]
>> And we can think of this as a different
or maybe the true
generalization of the second price
auction.
So now we get some bids
B1 through BN.
And we have to decide what to do with
them.
It's helpful to have some notation for
what's the highest bid, what's the
second highest bid, and so on. It's not
necessarily the first bidder is the
highest. So just some notation, I'm
going to write B1 in parentheses. This
is going to say which among these bids
is the highest.
And then I'll write B2 in parentheses to
say which among these bids is the second
highest, all the way down
to B in parentheses N for the nth
highest among the bids, right?
Now I'm going to have my slots.
Say slot one
down to slot M.
And instead of writing it many times,
let me just describe what happens to the
Kth slot. Where K is an arbitrary or I
guess I was using J before, maybe I'll
call it the Jth slot.
The Jth slot.
So who gets the Jth slot? Well, the Jth
slot is going to go to the Jth highest
bidder as before. So the allocation rule
is going to be the same as the second
price auction. I allocate the good to
the Jth best good to the Jth highest
bidder.
So it's allocated
to Jth
highest bidder.
But the tricky thing is the payment. So
maybe I'll call it
PJ.
And remember this is a payment
per click.
Um well
it's easier I think to think Let's have
a little more space.
To think about alpha J
PJ. Because remember
I want each bidder to be charged their
externality.
So what I want to set equal to the
bidder's externality is the actual
amount they pay.
And the actual amount they pay is not
PJ, that's the amount they pay per
click. So they pay PJ per click times
the probability they're actually clicked
on, that's the expected amount that they
pay. So this is going to be the expected
payment.
So later we can divide by alpha J and
get a formula for PJ, but it's just when
we're thinking of the externality, it's
easier to think this way. Yes. Expected
expected payment per click, right?
Uh no no no. Uh
well, I guess it depends what you mean.
If alpha J is the probability per click
of the probability of a click, then this
is just the expected payment. Correctly.
No, no. Just Just PJ is the payment per
click, right?
>> Yeah. So, if I if I multiply the payment
per click
times my probability of a click, that
gives me my full expected payment,
right? If I pay 100 per click, and
there's a half chance of getting
clicked, then my expected payment is 50.
Cuz there's a half chance I get clicked
and pay 100, and
half chance I don't get clicked and pay
nothing.
If there's multiple clicks, then uh we
could more generally think of alpha j as
the expected number of clicks, and maybe
the expected number of clicks is more
than one, but in reality each time a
keyword is searched, there's a different
auction. Um
Uh well,
>> [laughter]
>> uh that that is how it used to be. Uh
now people have a lot of automated
bidding. Now people are using kind of
robots to bid on their behalf, so it's a
little more complicated, but originally
uh yeah, I mean maybe they were they
were batched a little bit, but uh
roughly uh yeah, you can change your bid
very very frequently. If
two people are searching for the same
keyword at the same time, Yeah, okay.
There's going to be some lag. Uh you
know, I I think formally what happened I
I don't know, you know, and some of this
may be proprietary. Firms are able to
change their bid very quickly. I know
firms are able to change their bid maybe
like a second interval. So, maybe all
the all the keywords that were searched
a given second would use those bids, and
then when your bid changed, uh all the
uh auctions in the next second would use
the new bid. Um and there was actually
when they were when it used to be like
when they used to use uh
things that were not strategy-proof, and
people were kind of gaming it, this is
what would happen. I mean, there was
people investing in technology to change
their bids and update their bids very
very quickly. Um yeah. But yeah,
probably not literally per auction, uh
but every auction in a second, uh which
is a lot, but yeah. So, that's why we're
kind of just considering like is there
one click or one set of the number?
Yeah, I mean, it doesn't I mean, it it
mathematically doesn't matter at all,
right? If you want to think of alpha j,
one way of thinking of this is this is
the
uh probability per click, and maybe our
bid is relevant for a batch of 100
auctions, and then you could just
multiply alpha j every alpha by 100, and
then you get the expected number of
clicks in this batch of auctions that's
relevant for a bid.
Great. Um okay, so here's our expected
payment and [clears throat]
uh I was trying to be consistent about
superscripts, but I wasn't. Oh, no, I
was over here. Okay, sorry. This should
be alpha j, I guess.
Uh
I don't know if I've been consistent.
Uh I wasn't consistent over here. Change
this.
So, this is actually right. B3 is
actually the third bidder, so that's a
subscript. Alpha 2 is the second bid
slot, so it's a superscript. Um so, I
think my notation is good.
Okay, so now we want to compute what is
the externality that bidder j is
imposing on the other bidders. So, the
first question is who does bidder j Who
is bidder j affecting?
Which So, over here we thought bidder
one was affecting bidder two and bidder
three. Who is uh
Which bidders is bidder j's bid
affecting? If bidder j were gone, whose
allocation would change?
All those.
Everyone afterwards? Okay, yeah. So,
what we need to compute is what is the
externality that bidder j is imposing on
everyone after bidder j, because these
people above him are not going to be
changed, right? If bidder j weren't
there, those people are still going to
win.
So, it's going to be a sum,
and let's sum it over everyone after
bidder j.
So,
this is the jth highest bidder. We want
to sum from the j plus first highest
bidder
to n, right?
So, within our sum, we want to say what
is the externality imposed on the kth
highest bidder?
So, if I'm the kth highest bidder, where
k is bigger than j,
when j's here, I get the kth slot.
But if j were not here, what slot would
I get?
The k minus one slot, right? So, the
externality, the change in my
click-through rate, is alpha k minus
This is the externality. Without j, I
would have become the k minus first
highest bidder, and I would have gotten
the k minus first highest slot. With j,
I'm only the kth highest bidder, and I
get the kth slot.
But I have to multiply that change in
the click-through rate times my value
per click. Again, we don't know that
bidder's value, but the way we compute
externalities is if people are bidding
truthfully.
And we have notation. What is our
notation for the bid of the kth highest
bidder?
Right. It's just b
to the superscript k.
So, this is our formula, and this fully
specifies the auction, because we've
specified
who
which bidder each slot is assigned to,
and we've specified the payment per
click for each of these slots. Okay? But
now let's try to understand a little bit
what this uh formula looks like. So,
let's dig in a little more. Let's go
over here.
Let's try to interpret this.
Let's divide both sides by
uh
alpha j.
So, we're going to see that
pj,
the payment per click in the jth slot,
is going to equal a sum
of k equals j plus one to n
of bk
times
alpha k minus one
divided by
alpha j.
Good?
And
we can see that the amount that we pay
in the jth slot
is a sum over all the lower bids, but
each of the lower bids is multiplied by
some coefficient here. So, let's
introduce notation for this. Let's call
this
wk,
and let's see what we can say about
uh wk.
Well, first, wk is greater than equal to
zero. In fact, strictly greater than
zero.
Uh
Why?
Well, alpha k minus one is strictly
higher than alpha k. That's our
assumption. The higher slots, higher
slot meaning lower numbered slot, right?
The higher slots have a higher
click-through rate. So, each of these
numbers is strictly positive. Now, let's
try to see what the sum of these numbers
are.
So, let's look at
w
j plus one
all the way up to w n.
Well,
let's go through it. W j plus one,
let's plug in j plus one for k. We're
going to get alpha j
minus alpha j plus one
divided by alpha j.
Plus, well, the next term is going to be
alpha j plus one
minus alpha j plus two
over alpha j.
All the way Well, what's the last term
going to be? We have wn here, so we're
going to have alpha
n minus one
minus alpha n
over alpha j.
Well,
alpha j is underneath everything, so we
can make this into a single fraction,
and we add alpha j plus one
Sorry, we subtract alpha j plus one, and
then we add it back.
We subtract alpha j plus two, and then
we add it back. So, this is going to be
what's called a telescoping sum. It's
going to simplify a lot, and we're only
going to get the first term
and the last term.
Everything in the in every intermediate
term is going to cancel.
So, what we're going to get is
alpha j
minus alpha n
over alpha j.
Yes. What's the significance of bk in
the sum if we're if each of the terms is
multiplied by a different value of bk?
So, it's not bk multiplied by alpha k.
Um just as interpretation. So, let's see
in a second, and then I think it'll
it'll make sense. So, what can we say
about this value? Well, in general, this
value is less than or equal to one.
And in fact, it's going to equal one if
alpha n equals zero. So, if we have
fewer slots than bidders, this is going
to equal one. Uh you might worry if
there's fewer slots than bidders,
are we ever going to divide by zero? It
turns out the top's going to become zero
before the bottom does, and we're not
really going to have to worry about it,
but I won't go through the details. So,
it turns out this is going to be less
than or equal to one,
with equality
if m is strictly less than n. If there's
fewer slots than bidders, which is a
pretty standard uh phenomenon, right?
You have many many advertisers wanting
to advertise on just a few limited
slots. So, generally, n is going to be
bigger than m, and I guess the sort of
trick I've used here is if m is bigger
than n, well, let's just create null
slots beyond the mth. Uh I guess I
should have said this, right? Um
We we could have just stopped, or we
could say, "Yeah, well, there's actually
an m plus first slot, but it just has
zero click-through rate. It's just a a
fake slot." And if we do that, then all
these alphas are well defined. They're
just all zero after the mth.
And if we do that, then we see that this
sum is going to be exactly one.
So, why did we do this sum? The sum was
for interpretation.
What is the payment per click that I
make if I'm the jth highest bidder?
It's a weighted average of all the bids
that are lower than mine.
The weights are non-negative
and the sum of the weights, well, in
this general case here is exactly one.
So, it's exactly a weighted average.
And now we have kind of a nice
comparison, right? Because
I'll go back over here.
If we looked at the GSP
or the generalized second price auction,
PJ
was what? Just using our notation, what
was PJ? What was the payment per click
for the jth slot?
Right. It was
the j plus first highest bid.
Under the
VCG mechanism,
PJ, well, we have this formula over
here, but let's just check.
K ranges from j plus one to n.
So, these range from bj plus one to n.
So, we get a weighted average
of all the lower bids.
And we can exactly see why
the VCG or at least there's some
intuition for why under the GSP
we see bid shading.
And under the VCG
bidding truthfully is optimal.
In short, it turned out in the GSP,
well, it seemed like the right
generalization to have you bid to have
you pay the next highest bid, that was
actually too high.
And as a result, people wanted to shade
their bids.
And in a VCG, you actually asked to pay
less relative to your bids.
Instead of paying the next highest bid,
you pay a weighted average of the next
highest bid, the next highest, the next
highest, and so on. And these later bids
are lower than uh than this bid here.
In particular, let's look at
kind of a special case
which is kind of instructive.
>> [snorts]
>> What if alpha one
So, this technically isn't covered by
assumption cuz we assumed it was strict,
but we can think of this as a limit,
right? So, let's say there's n bidders
and the n slots are all basically the
same.
So, we have n bidders
and we have n identical slots.
Okay?
How would people bid in the
GSP?
Would you want to bid your evaluation
for the slot? How how would you bid if
you were in the
in the GSP and you knew there were n
slots?
Uh yeah. You could end up bidding
anything and still you could just end up
getting it if you're like in the last
one.
It doesn't really matter cuz you'll all
have the same money.
Right. So, here there's really no
scarcity, right? There's n slots,
they're all equally good. There's no
competition between the bidders at all.
There's It's not like we're fighting for
that top slot cuz the next slot's just
as good.
So, we see that the GSP is going to
wildly uh is going to induce really, you
know, intense bid shading. People are
going to shade their bids a lot. In
fact, people are generally going to bid
zero. There's no shortage, I can just
bid zero, I'll still get one of the n
slots uh and I'm happy with that.
So, you might think, well, how is the
VCG going to get people to be truthful
at all?
Right? How could we possibly get people
to pay anything if there's no scarcity?
Well, what is the payment going to be
um
the payment rule going to be in the VCG?
Well, what are these weights going to be
if all the alphas are the same?
Zero.
So, in fact, in the VCG mechanism in
this special case, people are always
just going to pay zero.
So, you might think, oh, VCG, how do we
kind of get something for nothing? Well,
it's sort of like if people had a really
strong incentive to shade their bid in
the
GSP, then the VCG is kind of going to
shade on their behalf and just charge
everyone zero anyway, and then people
are going to be willing to be truthful.
Um so, nothing comes for free.
How do we get people to bid more?
They're willing to bid more because of
the function of their bids, they're
asked to pay less. And that's kind of
the I think the key uh idea or key
insight of the VCG mechanism.
So, maybe in the last
15 minutes, we'll try to I'd like to go
over maybe the the general formula for
VCG beyond this setting. So, it turns
out the VCG mechanism, it was applied to
this setting of ad auctions, but it
makes sense and it works in a much more
abstract setting and we're just going to
go over uh how that works.
So, now I'll say kind of abstract VCG.
So, the general setting of VCG is, well,
we're having to make some decision for
all the bidders. Here the decision was
how we match the bidders to the ad
slots.
Maybe the decision is, do we build a
bridge or
um
you know,
there are many many things it could be.
How we allocate some item among the
bidders, there there could be many many
things. So, we're going to be totally
abstract and the decision
is just going to be some abstract x in
some set x. But if you want to make it
concrete, think of x as the allocation
of bidders to slots. Maybe another
classic example would be the allocation
of planes to airline landing slots. Uh
this is a
or airport landing slots. This is a
classic application of VCG.
Or maybe routing in internet protocols,
routing of packets through the network.
That might be what x represents. But the
crucial thing is x is a collective
decision that affects everyone. X does
not represent bidder one gets slot one.
It represents the complete mapping of
bidders to slots or the complete
allocation of airplanes to landing slots
and so on.
Now,
we now need to describe the bidders'
preferences
or the players' preferences. So, we
have, let's say, player i
has valuation
vi.
Now, before, vi was just a number. When
we were in a setting where we were
allocating a good, my valuation was just
how much am I willing to pay for that
good.
But now my valuation needs to specify
how much I value every possible social
decision that's made. Let me say social
or collective decision.
So, now my valuation is a function vi
from x to r.
So, I'm just going to call it vi, but
remember it's a much richer object now.
It's not just one number that says how
much do I value an item, it's an entire
mapping that says, if this is the uh
allocation of bidders to to auction
slots, that's how much utility I get. If
we have a different allocation of
bidders to auction slots, here's how
much utility I get, and so on. Yeah. Why
do you have to consider how if how other
bidders are like putting in different
auction slots? It doesn't matter. If
you're in a fixed auction slot, can it
just be your auction slot to your
utility? It's a good point. So,
if we're willing to impose more
structure on x, maybe x says, this is
what you get, this is what you get, this
is what you get, and my valuation only
depends on my component of x. But at
this level of generality, we're not even
assuming that that kind of structure,
and it may be that uh
you know, we we want to be The point is
this is more general, so it may be that
if we're allocating planes to landing
slots, I also really like if my
competitor gets a bad slot. I don't just
care about getting a good slot. So, in
principle, that could be the case.
Maybe there are ways we could restrict
it, but this is more general and it
makes the notation cleaner, so we're not
going to impose that assumption. But I
think that's a very reasonable
assumption. Yeah.
Um okay.
So,
what are we going to do?
Well,
before in a second price auction, we had
this idea that people were bidding
truthfully. We'd also like people to bid
truthfully, but if we want people to bid
truthfully, well, we have to just ask
them what their valuation function is.
And that's what the mechanism is going
to do. We're going to say, everyone,
tell me what your valuation function is.
So, instead of telling me just how much
you value one item, we're going to say,
tell me how much you value every
possible social decision.
So,
the mechanism
will say elicits
reports
and we'll often denote these v1 hat
through vn hat.
So, what's the interpretation here? V1
is bidder one's true valuation function.
V1 hat is a effectively a bid. It's what
bidder one It's the valuation function
that bidder one reports to the
mechanism. And that may not be truthful.
We want to make sure that people have
the right incentives to report
truthfully.
Uh but they're reporting an entire
function, which may be a little bit
confusing and abstract at first.
So, what does the mechanism do?
So, we have 5 minutes. Just going to
write two formulas, but they're a little
long.
So, just like an auction, a mechanism is
going to just specify two things. It's
going to have to specify an allocation
rule and a payment rule. Right?
So, we need an allocation rule
and a payment rule.
The allocation rule says, "If these are
the reported valuation functions that
people send to me,
how what decision am I going to choose?"
And the payment rule says, "If these are
the valuation functions that are
reported to me, how much am I going to
ask each agent to pay?"
So, the allocation rule
we need to define x v1 hat
vn hat.
These are the valuation functions that
are reported.
X of this is going to be the allocation
or the decision
allocation or decision rule.
We use these interchangeably.
Well,
we want to allocate things efficiently.
So, what does that mean?
This is going to be in the argmax.
I think the notation here is a little
tricky.
of x prime
in x
for the sum.
So, let's just understand what this is.
This says, "If we choose decision x
prime,
what is the sum of the players'
utilities
when we compute them with respect to
what they report?"
Taking the argmax of this says, "We're
going to choose the decision that
maximizes the sum of the reported
valuations." What we'd really like to do
is maximize the sum of the true
valuations, but we don't know those. We
only know the reports. So, all we can do
is take in the reported valuation
functions and choose the decision that
makes the sum of the valuations as large
as possible.
And that's what this is, and sometimes
we call this x star to denote that this
is efficient.
I think this is a bit abstract, so uh
any
questions on this?
No? Good.
Okay.
There could be multiple maximizers, and
we'll just choose one of them. Doesn't
matter. If there's If there's two things
that would be efficient. So, as an
example, if we were in the auction
context, then this would be the
allocation that gives the highest uh
bidder the first slot,
the second highest bidder the second
slot, and so on. That's what x star
would represent.
And v1 hat would say would be the report
of how much I value each slot, each
click.
Now, the payment rule is exactly what we
said before. We want to charge each
bidder their externality.
Okay?
So, ti
of v1 hat through vn hat
is saying, "If these are the valuation
functions that are reported by the
bidders, how much are we going to charge
bidder i?"
We're going to charge bidder i,
informally, the externality
imposed on all others.
Okay? So, let's write that more
formally.
What is the externality imposed on all
others? It's
how well everyone else would do if
bidder i weren't there
minus how well they actually do.
That's what the externality is. So, how
well would they do if bidder i weren't
there? Well, let's just look at the best
they could possibly do. So, the best
they could possibly do if bidder i
weren't there
would be this.
I'm looking at everyone other than
bidder i.
I'm using their reported valuation
functions,
and I'm saying, "If we chose x prime,
this is how well everyone but player i
would do."
And let me choose the allocation that
makes those people as well off as
possible.
So, I want to maximize the welfare of
everyone other than bidder i.
That's what we could do if bidder i
weren't here. And we do Or in other
words, if we didn't care about bidder i,
this is how well everyone else could do.
Now, I want to subtract from that how
well they actually do. How well they do
uh given that bidder i is present.
How well do they actually do? Well, it's
the sum over j not equal to i
vj hat. But now, what I want to plug in
here is the decision that's actually
chosen.
And the decision that's actually chosen
is this one up here.
And this is the formula.
It's a little abstract.
Put this in parentheses.
And if you go to the notes, you can see
a proof uh as to why
using this um
mechanism, it's always optimal for
bidders to be truthful. So, let me just
write that fact. This is a fact that you
can prove.
So, for each bidder i
and each valuation
function vi
bidding
vi hat equals vi. What I mean by that is
reporting
my true valuation to the mechanism
is optimal
no matter how everyone else bids.
And when I say no matter what others
bid, well, that's basically
vj hat
for j not equal to i.
So, whatever everyone else other than me
reports to the mechanism,
if my true value is vi,
bidding or reporting my true value vi is
going to be best for me. It's going to
be weakly better than any other bid.
Uh and this is sort of a
kind of
incredible property of the VCG
mechanism.
Uh the proof is like three lines, but
it's a little dense, so I encourage you
to check the notes uh to see the proof.
And maybe I'll
stop here a few minutes early, and I'm
happy to stick around to go over any
questions people have about